[MUSIC PLAYING]
ADAM BECKER: Fantastic.
Well, thank you Alex
for overpromising.
I hope to underdeliver.
And thank you everybody
for being here today.
I'm really excited to
be talking at Google.
Before I get
started, I just want
to gauge where the audience is.
So if you have a
background in physics,
like if you've ever taken a
course in quantum mechanics,
can you raise your hand?
OK.
So that's like maybe 1/2 to 2/3.
That's good.
If you have no formal
training in physics
and you just think that
quantum mechanics is cool
or that physics is
interesting, raise your hand.
Good.
So this talk is going
to be aimed primarily
or at the level of people
who haven't taken any courses
in quantum mechanics.
But at the end, in the Q&A,
we can get as technical
as we want.
There's all sorts of stuff that
I'm not mentioning in his talk,
which we can get
into in the Q&A.
So if you are annoyed that
I don't mention decoherence,
for example, we can talk
about it in the Q&A,
and I can explain why
I didn't mention it.
So let's talk about
quantum physics.
Quantum physics is fantastic,
but there's a problem with it.
There is a hole at the
heart of the theory.
And just to be clear,
quantum physics works.
It works tremendously well.
It is, by almost any
measure, the most successful
scientific theory that
humanity has ever devised.
It explains an enormous
variety of phenomena.
It's the physics
of the ultra tiny,
but it goes well beyond that.
It explains why the sun shines.
It explains why we can
see that the sun shines.
It is what almost
every single piece
of technology in this room
or in the world runs on.
It even explains why you're
not sinking through the chairs
that you're sitting in
right now because quantum
mechanics explains why
anything is ever solid.
So it's just a phenomenally
successful theory.
And anybody who says
otherwise has no idea
what they're talking about.
It is a good theory.
But there is a problem.
The problem is that
it is just not clear
what quantum physics is telling
us about the world around us.
The connection between
the theory, though it's
phenomenally successful,
and the world that we're in
is just not obvious.
And to explain what
I mean by that--
say that I want to figure
out where this marker is.
Right?
So right now, if I want
to use Newton's physics,
the pre-quantum
classical physics,
to figure out where
this marker is,
I need three numbers to
describe where it is.
I need to say, OK,
it's a certain height
above the ground.
It's a certain distance
in front of me.
And it's a certain
distance off to my left.
But if I want to say where this
thing is in quantum mechanics,
if I want to describe
its position,
I need more than three numbers.
I need an infinity of numbers
scattered across all of space.
And this is known
as a wave function.
And this is somewhat odd that
we need an infinity of numbers,
but oddness is fine.
The trouble with
quantum mechanics
isn't that it's strange.
Strangeness is OK.
The world is a strange place.
If our theories
weren't weird, they
wouldn't be able to
account for what we see.
The trouble is more
complex than that.
See, wave functions obey
this very, very nice equation
called the Schrodinger equation.
It's a really beautiful
differential equation.
It sort of smells
like a law of physics.
Right?
It's the quantum mechanics
equivalent of Newton's
second law, F equals ma.
It's a good equation.
We like it.
It's pretty.
It says that wave
functions wave.
It says that they
undulate smoothly,
and they don't make
sudden changes.
They don't do anything-- well,
they do some surprising things,
but they don't make
any sudden moves.
But the strange thing is that
wave functions don't always
obey the Schrodinger equation.
Sometimes when we go
and look for a thing,
the wave function of
that thing suddenly
doesn't obey the Schrodinger
equation anymore.
The Schrodinger
equation is temporarily
suspended when we
make a measurement,
and instead, the wave
function collapses.
All those numbers scattered
across all of space,
they go to zero everywhere
except in the place where
we found the object.
Now that's somewhat strange.
Right?
Like I said, the
Schrodinger equation
smells like a law of physics.
We don't expect
the laws of physics
to get temporarily suspended
when we make a measurement.
That's just odd.
What's even odder is it's
kind of hard to define
what we mean by measurement.
What's a measurement?
Is a measurement when I measure?
If the measurement's
only when I measure,
why am I giving you a talk
about quantum mechanics
when it only applies to me?
Solipsism isn't really
a good look on anybody,
and it's not a good
look for physics.
Is it only when humans measure?
Now, Einstein asked, can a
mouse collapse a wave function.
That doesn't seem
quite right either.
It seems like it
shouldn't really
have anything to do with
life or consciousness.
That's not where we want to
go, and that doesn't really
make the idea of measurement
less weird anyway.
Maybe it's when a
big thing interacts
with this world of the ultra
tiny, the world of the quantum.
But there is no experimental
evidence that that's correct.
And in fact, there is a
great deal of evidence
that suggests that
quantum mechanics doesn't
have that kind of size limit.
So there is just a
host of thorny problems
here about what we mean
by measurement when
wave functions collapse, what
prompts them to collapse,
what's going on here.
And this is given
a special name.
It's called the
measurement problem.
Now it's tempting to say that
what's really going on here
is that the wave function
isn't a thing in the world.
It's just a measure of
probability in some way.
And that is the standard way of
thinking about wave functions
is that they just tell us
the probability of finding
a thing at a particular spot.
And then, the idea of collapse,
it looks somewhat less strange.
Because then you know, OK,
we don't know where it is.
And then we look and we find it.
And now we know where it is.
And so the probability
of it being elsewhere
has gone to zero, and that's
why wave functions collapse.
But it can't be quite
that straightforward
because wave functions do
some things that we associate
with physical waves,
like water waves
or sound waves or light waves.
Wave functions can actually
cause interference patterns
to appear.
That's not something that we
think of mere probabilities
as being able to do.
That doesn't mean that
it's not probability.
It just means that if it is,
it's not straightforward.
There has to be a more
complicated story here
to explain what's going on.
And there's also
the question of, OK,
so before we measure,
where is the object that's
described by this sort of
spread out wave function.
Where is the marker
before we look
for it if its wave function is
scattered across all of space?
Now, the standard answer here
is to say that it's not really
in one place or another.
It's in multiple places at once.
And we don't see markers in
more than one place at once,
but maybe subatomic particles,
maybe atoms and molecules
can perform that kind of trick.
But if we concede
that, if we say, yeah,
that's definitely
what's going on,
then we run into the most famous
version of the measurement
problem, which is
Schrodinger's cat.
You knew that this was coming.
It's a talk on quantum physics.
So Schrodinger put
this together in 1935.
He said, OK, say that you take
a cat and a bunch of equipment.
You seal it inside of a box.
You can't see what's
going on in there.
But what you've put
in there with the cat
is a very weak
radioactive source, a lump
of slightly radioactive metal.
And you've hooked it
up to a Geiger counter.
The Geiger counter
detects that radiation,
and if it detects
radiation, it releases
a hammer, which smashes
the vial of cyanide,
which kills the cat.
So if measurement is really
what collapses wave functions,
then the wave function
of this whole system
shouldn't collapse
until you open the box.
In other words, this
piece of radiation
that comes out from the
radioactive metal, that's
definitely a quantum object.
It's a small thing.
Right?
So it definitely obeys the
laws of quantum physics, which
means that in this traditional
way of thinking about wave
functions as probability,
it means that it's
both been released and
remains in the metal, which
means that the Geiger counter
both goes off and doesn't
go off.
Which means that the hammer
falls and doesn't fall,
the cyanide is smashed
and doesn't smash,
and the cat is dead and
alive until we open the box.
And Schrodinger-- here he is--
said, this is ridiculous.
Maybe subatomic particles can be
in more than one place at once,
but cats are definitely
not both dead and alive
until we open the box.
That just can't be right.
That doesn't make any
sense, and the fact
that this is what
the theory seems
to imply with the equation that,
by the way guys, I wrote down,
that seems wrong.
Right?
That doesn't seem to be the
way that the world works.
And that doesn't mean that
quantum physics is wrong.
It's definitely not wrong.
It's just not done yet.
It's not complete or there
is something else beyond it.
And this shouldn't be
controversial, right?
The idea that our
scientific theories
aren't the whole
story, yeah, sure
there's going to
be another theory.
Nobody thinks that our
scientific theories
that we have right now
are the end of the story.
And that's all that
Schrodinger was trying to say.
He was saying there's
something incomplete here
in our understanding of what's
going on in quantum physics.
But despite the
fact that this seems
reasonable and
straightforward, most
of Schrodinger's contemporaries
profoundly disagreed with him.
So people like Niels Bohr
or Werner Heisenberg--
Bohr is the guy on the
left of that picture
from my perspective.
So I guess right from
your perspective.
Heisenberg is the younger
one on the other side.
So Bohr and Heisenberg,
two of the other founders
of quantum physics,
they profoundly
disagree with
Schrodinger, as did
many of Schrodinger's
contemporaries
and many of the other people who
put together quantum physics.
They said no.
This is wrong.
This whole thing with the
cat, it's a misunderstanding.
Some of them said,
yeah, it's just
wrong to talk about
what's going on in the box
before we open it because
before we look is, in
principle, unobservable.
And it's unscientific to talk
about unobservable things.
In fact, it's meaningless to
talk about unobservable things.
This is the lesson of the
philosophy of language
that comes out of
quantum physics.
Others said, no, no, no, no.
It's not that it's meaningless,
it's that opening the box
really does force the
cat to be dead or alive.
And until we look, it
really isn't either one.
Others said, no, no, no, no, no.
You've completely
misapplied this theory
that you helped develop.
Quantum physics has,
by necessity, a split
between the measurer
and the measured.
And the problem with the cat
experiment that you've set up
is you're trying to get
rid of that division.
And that's what's
leading to the confusion.
And others said,
no, you're trying
to say that quantum physics
tells us how the world is.
Quantum physics isn't
about how the world is.
Quantum physics is
just a tool that we
use to predict the
outcomes of measurements.
That's all it is.
It's an instrument.
It's not a theory about
the state of the world.
And this collection of vague
related questionably coherent
contradictory claims, this
is known as the Copenhagen
Interpretation.
This is named after the home
of Niels Bohr's institute
in Copenhagen, which was
the center of the physics
world for much of the first
half of the 20th century.
And the Copenhagen
Interpretation, like I said,
it seems somewhat contradictory.
It seems somewhat vague.
What does it have to say
about the measurement problem?
What does it say leads to
wave function collapse?
What does it say
is going on there?
How do we define
what measurement is?
How do we say when wave
functions collapse?
When does the Schrodinger
equation apply,
and when is it suspended?
The standard answer that the
Copenhagen Interpretation
gives to all of these
thorny questions
at the heart of the theory
is somewhat unsatisfying.
Basically, it says,
shut up and calculate.
And this is not quite
as foolish as it first
appears because, again, quantum
physics works remarkably well.
It is incredibly good.
I can't stress this enough.
I mean, quantum
physics is really
responsible for most of the
technological breakthroughs
of the last 90 years.
It is an incredibly good
theory, and these questions,
at the heart of it,
really seem very thorny.
And so you have a
choice of either
trying to bang your head
against these questions
or contribute to one of
the greatest revolutions
in the history of science,
a revolution that gave rise
not only to much of
modern technology,
but much of modern science.
I mean, the whole
field of genetics
was based on imaging
breakthroughs
that came from quantum
physics, for example.
But shutting up and calculating,
saying all of these things
that the Copenhagen
Interpretation wants
to tell us, it is unsatisfying.
And I'll take
questions at the end.
I really will.
This talk is not going to take
the whole time, nowhere near.
But I'm excited to
hear your question.
So there is a problem,
shutting up and calculating.
There are several problems.
One problem is that
we want to understand
what is going on in the world.
Quantum physics tells
us why the sun shines,
but if quantum
physics really is just
an instrument for
predicting outcomes,
quantum physics doesn't
tell us why the sun shines.
It has no explanatory
power at all.
It only has predictive power.
So it doesn't explain why I'm
not passing through the floor.
It doesn't explain
why I can see.
It just says I won't
pass through the floor.
It doesn't tell us where
those things come from.
It doesn't give us a
picture of the world.
And if that sounds a
little bit wishy-washy,
let me make it more clear.
Quantum physics, if the
Copenhagen Interpretation
is correct, there's no
reason why it's true.
There's no reason why it works.
In fact, its success
is just a coincidence
because quantum physics,
according to the Copenhagen
Interpretation, isn't about
anything in the world.
There's nothing
in the world that
is even approximately described
by the equations of quantum
physics.
And if that's true, why
does the theory work?
What makes it true?
The fact that it works
at all, even though it
has no connection to
anything in reality,
would be nothing
short of a miracle,
a phenomenal
coincidence, if it's just
a trick for calculating that has
no relationship to the things
in the world around us.
On top of that, there are
some scientific projects
that we want to do
as physicists, which
the Copenhagen Interpretation
explicitly or implicitly makes
very difficult or impossible.
We want to think
that measurement
is a physical process.
And physical processes should
be amenable to analysis.
We should be able to come up
with a physical theory of how
measurement works.
But the Copenhagen
Interpretation
says no, you can't do that.
There is no need or way
to come up with a quantum
theory of measurement.
In fact, Niels Bohr
himself said that coming up
with a quantum
theory of measurement
was fundamentally misguided
as a scientific project.
We also-- and I mean, this
is near and dear to my heart,
this next one--
we want to be able
to do cosmology.
We want to be able to study
the entire universe at once.
But if we have to
split the universe
into the measured and the
measurer, we can't do that.
And if we have to
split the universe
into the measured
and the measurer,
we have an even bigger problem.
We want to account for classical
physics, the physics of Isaac
Newton, using quantum physics.
That's why the
theory was developed.
It was developed to
explain situations
that we couldn't explain
using classical physics.
And yet, if measurements are
a necessary part of the theory
and those measurements cannot
be described using quantum
physics, they can only be
described using classical
physics-- again, as Niels
Bohr and company said--
then we can't ground classical
physics in quantum physics.
If anything, it's
the other way around.
The logical foundations
of quantum physics
require classical physics.
And that seems really strange,
especially because there's
nothing particularly special
about classical physics.
Bohr and Heisenberg, they
said things like, oh,
the idea of measurement has
to be grounded in classical
physics because that's the
way our intuitions work--
they read a lot of Kant--
and that's not true.
Because classical physics is
profoundly counter-intuitive.
Our intuitions are
no more classical
than they are grounded in
witchcraft or astrology.
Classical physics has
many surprising results.
If you've ever done that thing
where you sit in a spinny chair
and you hold a bicycle
wheel, I didn't
see that coming the
first time I did that.
I don't think any of us do.
So yeah, that can't
be right either.
So the Copenhagen Interpretation
is profoundly unsatisfying,
both scientifically
and philosophically.
Now it's time for a
couple of disclaimers.
So here's the thing.
Despite the fact that the
Copenhagen Interpretation
is unsatisfactory, it is still
the default interpretation.
It is the standard
interpretation
of quantum physics today.
It is what is used in
most popular science books
on the subject.
It is what is presented in
basically every single widely
used quantum physics textbook
in undergraduate and graduate
courses.
I was exposed to it
in that way as well.
It's what you learn in school.
It is what many, if not most,
physicists believe to be true.
And they believe this to hold
the answer to the measurement
problem, especially
older physicists,
as the Copenhagen Interpretation
was once massively
overwhelmingly dominant.
Its dominance has declined
over the last few decades.
So the first disclaimer
is what I just
told you is a minority view.
I am a minority.
What I just told you is
not the standard story
that you get in a
quantum physics class.
So given that this
is a minority view,
why am I so sure that I'm right?
Why am I so willing
to come up here
to Google and other places
I've been giving this talk
and say, yeah, no, the
Copenhagen Interpretation
doesn't work?
Well, there is definitely
some controversy
over the foundations of quantum
physics among physicists,
but the history and philosophy
of quantum physics, that's
a different story.
In broad strokes, there
is an understanding
of what happened over
the last 90 years
in the development
of quantum physics
and the philosophy underpinning
the stories that we
tell about quantum physics.
And that history and
philosophy is wildly
unknown to most physicists.
Physicists have a set of
historical and philosophical
myths that they tell
amongst themselves,
kind of folk history, that's
passed down from generation
to generation of physicists,
either explicitly
or implicitly, about the
history of quantum physics
and why we believe
the things that we're
told to believe about it.
That folk history is very wrong.
It is just, as a matter of
historical fact, incorrect.
And I'm going to explain to
you what that folk history is
and then tell you what
actually happened,
which leads me to my
second disclaimer, which
is that the best psych research
suggests that if you're
trying to debunk a myth,
you shouldn't repeat
the myth first.
I'm going to throw
caution to the wind
and tell you this folk
history, this completely
mythical account of the
history of quantum physics.
And then I'm going to
tell you why it's wrong.
So with all the stuff that
I'm about to tell you, take it
with a grain of
salt. So here we go.
Once upon a time,
there was a group
of phenomenally talented
physicists working
in a loose team in the first
quarter of the 20th century
to try to understand
what was going on
in the world of the ultra
tiny, the world of atoms
and subatomic particles.
Now this team didn't
have a leader per se,
but they had a kind of
spiritual guide in their quest.
And that was Niels
Bohr, who again, is--
he's the older guy in the
picture over off on the side.
And this team also included
phenomenally talented
physicists like
Werner Heisenberg
in the middle, Pauli
sitting across from Bohr,
and many other
physicists besides.
Erwin Schrodinger, Louis de
Broglie, a wide collection
of physicists.
And over the course of the first
quarter of the 20th century,
they developed the first real
theories of quantum mechanics.
And with these theories came
a single unified picture
of how to think about
quantum mechanics
called the Copenhagen
Interpretation.
And the Copenhagen
Interpretation
said questions about
what's happening
before you look at quantum
objects are meaningless.
It's not sensical to
even ask those questions.
The world is
fundamentally random,
and quantum mechanics
is the best theory
that we can come up with
to understand what's
going on in the quantum world.
And this really bothered
Albert Einstein.
Most physicists were very happy
to accept this, but Einstein--
Einstein had once been a
bomb-throwing revolutionary
in his youth.
He had blown up
the physics world
with special relativity
and then 10 years later,
general relativity.
But that was long ago.
Now he was old.
He was stuck in his ways.
He was conservative,
and he couldn't
accept that quantum physics
could be fundamentally random.
He couldn't accept that the
world wasn't deterministic.
He was sure that the theory
had to be self-contradictory
or if not contradictory,
incomplete or wrong
in some fundamental way because
determinism had to be true,
according to Einstein.
So he developed a set of
thought experiments intended
to show that the theory
was contradictory.
And in particular, he
went after this thing
called the Heisenberg
Uncertainty Principle.
And the Heisenberg
Uncertainty Principle
says that you can't know both
the position and the velocity--
really the momentum,
but whatever--
the position and the momentum
of an object at the same time
to arbitrary precision.
He came up with a bunch
of thought experiments
to try to show that
this wasn't true,
but Bohr and Bohr's
team of researchers
showed at every turn that
Einstein was incorrect, that he
had misunderstood things.
And this culminated in
a thought experiment
where Einstein
devised a box filled
with light that was
hanging on a scale
spring with a clock
attached to it
and a little door in the side.
And he showed that you
could use this to get around
a different uncertainty
relationship in quantum
physics, the energy time
uncertainty relation.
But Bohr took a
look at this thing
and proved that Einstein
was wrong for an incredibly
embarrassing reason.
He said, Einstein, you've
forgotten your own theory
of general relativity, which
shows that this cannot work.
You cannot use this device
to get around the energy time
uncertainty relationship.
Einstein, of course, was
incredibly embarrassed,
and he laid low for a while.
And then he came up with
a new thought experiment
that was going to show the world
that quantum physics couldn't
be correct.
And so he came up
with something called
the EPR thought
experiment, named
after Einstein and
his two co-authors
on the paper,
Podolsky and Rosen.
And the EPR paper
showed that you
had to be able to get around
the Uncertainty Principle,
and if you couldn't, that
would mean that either quantum
physics was incomplete or
that there was something going
faster than light somehow.
Bohr responded to this.
Einstein said,
nothing could possibly
be going faster than light.
That would be spooky
action at a distance.
Bohr gave a
response, brilliantly
dismissing Einstein's concerns.
Most physicists thought,
OK, that's the end of it.
We still don't quite know
which one could be right,
but it's a matter of philosophy.
We don't need to
think about that.
And then, 30 years later,
after both Bohr and Einstein
were dead, a physicist
named John Bell came along.
And he proved that Bohr was
right and Einstein was wrong
and that you could not have
some more complete theory of how
quantum physics works without
violating the predictions
of quantum physics.
And thus, the world was made
safe for quantum physics,
and everybody lived
happily ever after.
So how much of what I
just told you is true?
Not a whole lot.
Most of that is just wrong.
As a matter of
historical fact, if you
look at contemporary
evidence, letters
that people sent to each
other, lecture notes,
rather than looking at
people's recollections of what
happened years after the fact,
here's what actually happened.
It is true that Bohr
and Heisenberg and Pauli
and a group of
brilliant physicists
did put together the first true
theories of quantum physics.
It is true that
Einstein was among them
and that Einstein
didn't like the theory.
Einstein though, when these
debates between him and Bohr
started in the mid to late
1920s, he was in his 40s.
He wasn't exactly
old and senile.
He was in perfectly good shape,
and his main concern actually
had nothing to do with the fact
that quantum physics presented
a world that was
fundamentally random.
He had two major concerns
aside from that one.
That was like a secondary
or tertiary concern.
He was concerned that quantum
physics didn't give us
a real picture of the world
independent of observation.
So he's concerned about realism.
And he was also
concerned-- and he
felt that these were two
sides of the same coin--
that because quantum
physics was not realist,
it was also doomed to have
non-locality, spooky action
at a distance,
things influencing
each other at a distance
faster than the speed of light,
instantaneously even.
Einstein felt that that couldn't
be right, not only because it
would violate relativity,
but because he
felt it would make it near
impossible to do science.
And he thought the Copenhagen
Interpretation was not only
not realist, but in so far as it
was realist, it was non-local.
And that, he could not abide.
And so he came up with a
series of thought experiments,
not to get around the
uncertainty principles,
mostly--
he had one or two like that--
mostly, his thought
experiments were
intended to show that quantum
physics was non-local.
This one was meant to show that
quantum physics was non-local.
It had nothing to do with
the energy time uncertainty
relationship aside from
the fact that it did
enter into the setup in a way.
But Einstein wasn't trying
to get around it in any way.
Bohr completely misunderstood
what Einstein was trying to get
at with this set up.
He thought Einstein was trying
to get around the energy time
uncertainty
relationship and thus
show that quantum physics
was inconsistent internally.
And then in order to answer
this supposed argument
from Einstein, Bohr brought
in a totally separate theory
that we still don't know how
to make consistent with quantum
physics in order to defend the
internal consistency of quantum
physics.
In other words, he gave a
profoundly inadequate argument
in response to an argument that
Einstein wasn't even making.
This should have been a massive
embarrassment for Niels Bohr,
and the standard story around
this thought experiment
is just completely confused.
Einstein, meanwhile, went
home and thought, shit,
Bohr still doesn't understand
what I'm getting at.
Let me make it simpler for him.
Thus was born the EPR
thought experiment.
And so after more debates
between Einstein and Bohr,
Einstein put together
this thought experiment,
the EPR thought experiment.
He published it with his
friends, collaborators Podolsky
and Rosen.
And after it came
out-- he actually
wasn't that happy with
the way that the paper was
put together, but he
then wrote about it
more in both letters and essays
through the rest of his life.
And he made it very clear
that the point of this thing
was that there was
a forced choice.
There was a choice
for quantum physics.
It could either be incomplete
and local or complete and
non-local.
So he was saying if the
Copenhagen Interpretation is
really the end of the
story, then something has
to be going faster than light.
Bohr gave a response
to the EPR paper.
It was really, really
hard to understand what
Bohr's response was saying.
And I'm not just saying
that because I've read it
and it makes no friggin' sense.
I'm saying that because Bohr
said it was hard to understand.
Bohr actually wrote about
this about 15 years later.
He wrote about these debates
that he had with Einstein,
completely mischaracterized
him, and then
when he got to
that part, he said,
I responded to the EPR paper.
I apologize for it being
so difficult to understand,
and then he moved on.
He didn't actually
explain what he meant.
He just said I know it
was hard to understand,
then he moved on.
Nonetheless, despite the
fact that Bohr's writing was
convoluted and
obscure, people felt
that these deep
philosophical puzzles
at the heart of the theory
were actually better addressed
by convoluted obscure writing
that made the answers unclear
rather than Einstein's very
clear direct writing that
made it obvious that
there was a problem here.
Part of that was because--
this confusion between obscurity
and profundity-- part of it
was that Bohr work
collaboratively
with a group of people
throughout his entire life.
And so he had more
people just on his side
politically whereas
Einstein was someone
who usually worked alone.
Einstein described himself
as going through life
like a one horse cart.
He did not really
work with people.
He didn't build a school
of thought around himself.
And part of it was just
that Einstein was making
a very uncomfortable argument.
Einstein was saying,
no, we're not done.
There's more work to be done
here whereas Bohr was saying,
no, it's cool.
Let's go off and keep doing
what we've been doing.
You don't have to
worry about this.
You can just shut
up and calculate.
Now part of the reason
that Bohr won the day
was also that there was a
proof by John von Neumann that
had been published in 1932
saying that there was no way
to come up with a more complete
theory of quantum physics,
that you couldn't add
something to the theory
and thus get something
not statistical, something
that gives you a more
complete picture of reality,
without actually changing the
predictions of the theory.
And nobody, not even
Einstein, wanted
to change the
predictions of the theory
because the theory is
phenomenally successful.
So von Neumann's proof
and Bohr's writings
helped quantum
physics carry along.
Now, there was just one problem.
Von Neumann, one of the
greatest mathematicians
to have ever lived,
made a mistake.
His proof was wrong.
This was actually pointed out by
the mathematician Greta Hermann
only a few years later.
But people didn't listen
to her, probably in part
because she was a woman.
And in the 1930s,
women were usually not
even allowed to teach at
universities much less
prove John von Neumann wrong.
So quantum physics just sort
of carried on with a hole
at its heart, piling
success upon success
over the course of the Manhattan
Project in World War II--
which incidentally, after
the Manhattan Project and all
that money poured into physics,
classroom sizes ballooned.
And the historian of
physics, David Kaiser at MIT,
has done a fascinating study
showing that the amount of time
devoted to
foundational questions
in quantum physics
in course syllabi
after World War II is inversely
proportional to classroom size.
So the larger the
classroom, the less time
they spent talking
about these questions
at the heart of quantum
physics, which makes some sense.
It's hard to address
them properly.
So after the war,
young physicist
named David Bohm came up with
a different way of thinking
about quantum physics.
He discovered that
you could just
take the equations as
they were and develop
an entirely different
picture of nature
to go along with it, one that
involved waves and particles
and was entirely deterministic.
In particular, it involved
particles surfing on waves.
And those waves would
guide the particles.
The waves could
interfere with themselves
and with other
waves, and they would
guide the motion
of the particles
to appear in the
correct locations
as to make the predictions
of quantum physics true.
And this became known
as pilot wave theory,
but this was largely
dismissed at the time,
in part because of
von Neumann's proof,
in part because Bohr's ideas
had already become entrenched
over the quarter
century before that,
and in part because
David Bohm had--
I'm going to go ahead
and call it shit luck.
David Bohm got really interested
in communism in the 1940s,
and then he got called up
before the House Un-American
Activities Committee
in the late 1940s,
chaired by someone who
probably haven't heard of named
Richard Nixon.
And then he got arrested
on contempt of Congress
because he wouldn't name names
because he had, you know,
integrity.
And then he was cleared
because it turns out
there is, in fact, a Fifth
Amendment to the United States
Constitution.
But it didn't matter.
He was blacklisted.
He was fired from
his job at Princeton.
And in fact, it was while he
was waiting for his day in court
that he developed pilot wave
theory, which had, by the way,
part of it had been
previously discovered
25 years earlier by
Louis de Broglie.
But Bohm independently
rediscovered it
and then completed the theory.
But Bohm was cleared
on all charges,
but he was blacklisted.
This happened right after he
submitted his papers, even
before they were published.
Couldn't find a job to work
in physics anywhere in the US
despite having recommendation
letters from Robert Oppenheimer
and Albert Einstein,
and ended up
having to go to
Brazil, at which point
his passport was
confiscated illegally
by the American consulate.
And he was trapped in Brazil for
almost five years, during which
time his papers were
published, discussed
without him being around.
He could only correspond
at a distance.
Many famous physicists
published papers or gave talks
explaining why Bohm
was wrong without Bohm
being there to defend himself.
And ultimately, his ideas were
forgotten by most physicists,
But not all.
John Bell read David
Bohm's papers in 1952
when they were first
published, and he immediately
knew that something was
wrong, not with Bohm's papers.
He had been told of John
von Neumann's proof, not of
Greta Hermann's disproof
of von Neumann's proof
because nobody knew about that.
But he had been told
of von Neumann's proof
even though he had always found
the Copenhagen Interpretation
hopelessly vague.
He said he knew it was rotten.
He figured there had
to be something better.
But then he was told
about von Neumann's proof
and figured, OK, I must just
not be understanding something.
And then he saw Bohm's
papers, worked through them,
and realized, no, there's
nothing wrong with this.
There must be a
flaw in this proof.
Problem, Bell
didn't speak German.
The proof was only
published in German.
He couldn't go in and figure
out what was wrong with it
until it was published in
English a few years later,
and by then, Bell was
busy with other things.
But in 1963, Bell came out
to the South Bay, actually.
He got invited to be
a visitor for a year
while he was on
sabbatical from CERN.
He was a visitor at
Slack just down the road.
And while he was at
Slack, he figured,
I really hate the
Copenhagen Interpretation.
It just can't be
right, and yet there's
this proof from von Neumann
and these other proofs
along the same lines.
I know that they're wrong
because there is nothing
wrong with Bohm's version
of quantum physics,
and these proofs
would rule it out.
Let me figure out what's
wrong with those proofs.
So he sits down, plays
with them for a while,
and he finds that von Neumann's
proof is not only broken,
he later characterized
it as silly.
So he publishes a paper showing
that von Neumann is wrong,
which gets lost in an editor's
desk for a couple of years.
He was really unfortunate.
But then he says, OK but
there's something else
funny about Bohm's version
of quantum physics.
It has this spooky
action at a distance.
The position of a
particle way over here
can instantaneously affect the
behavior of a pilot wave way
over here.
That seems strange.
No, is there a way
of not doing that?
Can I come up with something
like Bohm's version of quantum
physics without having
this instantaneous action
at a distance?
So he starts working on it,
and he realizes he can't do it.
And then he writes up a proof.
And that proof has become
known as Bell's theorem.
Bell's theorem is one
of the single most
profound and important results
in all of quantum physics.
It led to what's been
called the second quantum
revolution, which
among other things,
led to the entire field
of quantum information
processing, quantum
cryptography, quantum
computing, you name it.
It's also profoundly
misunderstood.
People often characterize Bell's
theorem not only as proving
that Bohr was right, but that
proving that you cannot have
anything like Bohm's
version of quantum physics.
Or they'll say, oh, it proves
that either something is going
faster than light or you have
hidden variables completing
the theorem, completing
quantum physics saying,
OK this is what's going
on before you look.
That's not true.
In fact, Bell himself said
that that wasn't true.
That wasn't what the
proof was about at all.
It is pretty much just a
proof that nature is not local
if it conforms with the
predictions of quantum physics.
There are only a couple
of ways out of that.
One of them was--
oh, sorry hold on.
If you want to learn more
about Bell's theorem,
it is a whole subject
for a talk by itself.
I have an interactive
essay explaining it
in more detail on my website.
I'll leave that up
there for a moment.
But there are only a few
ways out of Bell's theorem.
People will sometimes
say that realism
is a way out of Bell's theorem.
That's actually not true either
because in order for realism
to be a way out, you
would need to deny
the existence of an external
reality to such an extent
that the idea of locality
itself would dissolve.
So that's kind of nuts.
But another way out
of Bell's theorem
was developed before
Bell did his work
by a guy named Hugh Everett,
who came up with what is now
known as the many-worlds
interpretation of quantum
physics, which says that no,
wave functions don't collapse.
Instead, when you do
Schrodinger's cat, what happens
is the radioactive
metal wave function
gets mixed up with the wave
function of the Geiger counter
and the cyanide in the cat.
And so now instead of
a piece of radiation
that's both in the metal
and not in the metal,
you have a cat that is
both dead and alive.
And then when you open the
box, your wave function
gets mixed up with these
other wave functions as well.
And now there is a copy of you
looking at a dead cat in a box
and sad and a copy
of you looking
at a living cat in a
box and happy, I guess,
that you didn't kill a cat.
In any event, this is another
way out of Bell's theorem.
You can come up with a version
of many-worlds that is local
because Bell's theorem
assumes that you only
have one universe.
But these are not the only
two options on the table.
There are many other
interpretations
of quantum physics available.
It's just that the
Copenhagen Interpretation
isn't one of them.
There are other
ways of doing this,
and given that there are ways
of understanding what's actually
going on in nature, just
throwing up your hands
and saying, I give
up, we can't do it,
there's no way to
understand it, seems
both profoundly inadequate
and, frankly, unscientific.
But you may be left
with another question
a much, much deeper and more
profound question, who cares.
If quantum physics works, then
why does any of this matter?
And it does work, as I've
said over and over again.
Quantum physics
definitely works.
So why does it matter what
it's telling us about the world
if we can use it to
do whatever we want?
I'm going to need to appeal to
a higher authority on this one.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Now another thing that people
often say is that for guessing
two identical theories,
two theories--
suppose you have two
theories, A and B,
which look completely
different psychologically,
different ideas
in them and so on.
But then all the consequences
that are computed
are exactly the same.
You may even say they even agree
with experiment [INAUDIBLE]..
The point is though, that the
two theories, although they
sound different
at the beginning,
have all consequences the same.
It's easy usually to
prove that mathematically
by doing a little
mathematics ahead of time
to show that the logic
of this one and this one
will always give
corresponding consequence.
Suppose we have
two such theories.
How are we going to
decide which one is right?
No way.
Not by science.
Because they both agree with
experiment to the same extent,
there's no way to distinguish
one from the other.
So the two theories,
although they
may have deeply different
ideas behind them,
may be mathematically identical.
And usually people say then
in science [INAUDIBLE],,
one doesn't know how
to distinguish them.
And that's right.
However, for
psychological reasons,
in order to get new
theories, these two things
are very far from equivalent
because one gives a man
different ideas than the other.
By putting the theory in a
certain kind of framework,
you get an idea what
to change, which
would be something, for
instance, in theory A, that
talks about something
that you say,
I'll change that idea in here.
But to find out what the
corresponding thing is
you're going to change in
here may be very complicated.
It may not be a simple idea.
In other words, a
simple change here
may be a very different theory
than a simple change there.
In other words, although they
are identical before they're
changed, there are
certain ways of changing
one which look natural,
which don't look natural
in the other.
Therefore psychologically,
we must keep
all the theories in our head.
And every theoretical
physicist that's any good
knows six or seven different
theoretical representations
for exactly the same physics.
And knows that
they're all equivalent
and that nobody is ever going
to be able to decide which
one is right at that level.
But he keeps them in his head
hoping that they'll give him
different ideas for guessing.
Incidentally, that reminds
me of another thing
and that is that the
philosophy or the ideas
around the theory--
there are a lot of ideas.
You say, I believe there is
a space-time or something
like that in order to
discuss your analyses.
That these ideas
change enormously
when there are very tiny
changes in the theory.
In other words, for
instance, Newton's ideas
about space and time agree
with experiment very well.
But in order to get the correct
motion of the orbit of Mercury,
which was a tiny,
tiny difference,
the difference in the character
of the theory with which you
started was enormous.
Reason is these are so
simple and so perfect.
They produce definite results.
In order to get
something that produces
a little different results,
has to be completely different.
You can't make imperfections
on a perfect thing.
You have to have
another perfect thing.
So the philosophical ideas
between Newton's theory
of gravitational and Einstein's
theory of gravitational
are enormous.
Their differences,
rather, are enormous.
What are these philosophies?
These philosophies
are really tricky ways
to compute consequences quickly.
A philosophy, which is sometimes
called an understanding
of the law, is simply a
way that a person holds
the laws in his mind so as to
guess quickly at consequence.
Some people have
said, and it's true
for instance, in the case
of Maxwell's equations
and other equations,
never mind the philosophy.
Never mind anything
of this kind.
Just guess the equations.
The problem is only
to compute the answers
so they agree with
experiment and is not
necessarily to have a philosophy
or words about the equation.
That's true in a sense.
Yes and no.
It's good in the sense
you may be if you only
guess the equation, you're
not prejudiced in yourself,
and you'll guess better.
On the other hand, maybe the
philosophy helped you to guess.
It's very hard to say.
For those people
who insist, however,
that the only thing
that's important
is that the theory
agrees with experiment,
I would like to make
an imaginary discussion
between a Mayan astronomer
and his student.
The Mayans were able to
calculate with great precision
the predictions, for
example, for eclipses
and the position of the moon
in the sky, position of Venus,
and so on.
However, it is all
done by arithmetic.
You count certain numbers,
you subtract some numbers,
and so on.
There was no discussion
of what the moon was.
There wasn't even a
discussion of the idea
that it went around.
There was only
calculate the time
when there would be
an eclipse or the time
when it would rise,
their full moon
and when it would rise
half moon, and so on.
Just calculate it only.
Suppose that a young man went
to the astronomer and said,
I have an idea.
Maybe those things
are going around
and there are balls
like rock out there.
We could calculate how they move
in a completely different way
then just calculate what
time they appear in the sky.
So of course, the
Mayan astronomer
would say, yes, how accurate
can you predict eclipses.
He said, I haven't developed
the thing very far.
He says, but we can
calculate eclipses
more accurately than
you can with your model,
and so you must not pay
any attention [INAUDIBLE]
mathematical scheme is better.
And there's a very
strong tendency
of people to say
against some idea.
If someone comes up
with an idea and says
let's suppose the
world is this way,
and you say to him, well, what
would you get for the answers
for such and such a
problem, and he says,
I haven't developed
it far enough.
And you say, well, we have
already developed much further,
and we can get the
answers very accurately.
So it is a problem
as to whether or not
to worry about
philosophies behind ideas.
[END PLAYBACK]
ADAM BECKER: So
it's certainly true
that you can use whatever
interpretation of quantum
physics you like and come up
with the same predictions.
And given that, there
is no test that you
can perform to show
which interpretation
of quantum physics is correct.
But the story of the world that
goes along with the theories
that we have in science plays a
big role in the actual practice
of science.
It actually influences
the way that we come up
with new theories to go
beyond the current theory.
It influences what
experiments we conduct,
and it influences how
we interpret the results
of those experiments.
Feynman gives an example of--
and this is in, by the way,
his book, "The Character
of Physical Law", which is a
compilation of the lectures
that I was going to
play a clip from.
Feynman gives the
example of someone
going to a Mayan
astronomer, back
when the Mayan civilization was
at its peak, and saying, look,
I know we have this
theory that allows
us to predict when
eclipses will happen
and when Venus will transit the
sun and all these other things
to phenomenal precision.
But the theory doesn't
tell us what Venus is
or what the moon is.
I have a theory that
tells us all those things.
And then the Mayan astronomer
says, OK but can you
do the same things we can do.
And the other guy
says, well no, I
haven't developed it fully yet.
It doesn't mean
that we shouldn't
listen to the other guy.
Right?
And it doesn't mean
that even if he
could get it to work just as
well as Mayan astronomy, that
doesn't mean that there is no
difference between the choices
we make in our theories.
It matters for the
progress of science.
And it matters beyond just
the realm of science as well.
It matters for the entire world.
Remember, throughout
the history of humanity,
this was at least in
Europe, the dominant way
of thinking about what
the universe looked
like throughout most
of human history.
The Earth is at the center,
and everything moves around us.
And it wasn't until
Copernicus in the 1500s,
that people started seriously
considering the possibility
that the Earth is not at
the center of everything.
And without that move,
without Copernicus uncentering
the Earth, it seems
unlikely that Darwin
would have had the
audacity to say, yeah,
humans are not at the
center of creation either.
We are just another part
of a giant tree of life.
And without those two insights,
our entire modern world,
not just science, but
culture, art, movies,
would look entirely different.
Kubrick would never have
been able to film 2001,
not that that's the pinnacle
achievement of humanity
in the 20th century, but
I really like that movie,
and I think it's an
important piece of art.
And there are other
very important pieces
of art, science, religion,
politics, economics.
All of the realms of human
experience and endeavor
are affected by the stories
that we get from our science.
And in fact, this is how we do
every other piece of science.
Nobody says, oh,
genes aren't real,
they're just a way of
explaining the outcomes
of electron microscope
observations and genetics
experiments.
Nobody says, or at least
physicists usually don't say,
space-time isn't real,
it's just something
that helps us understand
the outcomes at LIGO.
We don't say electromagnetic
fields aren't real.
We're very willing to
grant reality to things
except when it comes
to quantum physics,
and the reasons for that
are largely historical.
I've written a book that
is about all of this.
There were copies at
the back, but it looks
like everyone snapped them up.
That's great.
You can buy it online.
You can go find it
anywhere books are sold.
And if you do, that
will make me happy.
I hope you enjoy it.
You can get a hold of
me relatively easily
if you want to ask me questions
about anything in there.
I discuss all of this in much
greater detail in the book,
and the book is, like
this talk I hope,
understandable for people
who have no physics
background at all.
The intended audience is
just the interested public.
So with that, thank
you for your time.
Any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: I guess putting things
historically correct, Einstein
has also attributed to this
quote of God doesn't play,
doesn't roll the die
and play with dice.
And so that might have also
been taken out of context.
If he actually didn't--
his biggest problems
weren't with,
as you said, the
randomness but more
with this action at a distance.
It sounds like that quote was
also kind of out of context.
ADAM BECKER: Yes, I
think that's correct.
Given that Einstein famously
said that God doesn't play dice
with the universe, it sounds
like that was taken out
of context, given that his
primary problem with quantum
physics was not randomness.
I'm sorry, Alex, can you take
the computer and do that?
Yeah, thank you.
ALEX: [INAUDIBLE]
account, actually.
ADAM BECKER: Oh, OK that's fine.
So yeah.
I think that's right.
It's not so much
that it was taken out
of context as it is that it
was a real problem that he had.
He did not like the
randomness of quantum physics.
He just also didn't like other
things about quantum physics,
even more.
I mean, he also said, I
can't abide spooky action
at a distance.
That got closer to
his real problem.
And he also said some
very quotable things
about his problems with the
non-realism of the Copenhagen
Interpretation.
They're just not as well-known.
And I think that that's largely
because the idea of God playing
dice is this very sexy image
and also because it conforms
with this standard incorrect
narrative among physicists
about the history of physics.
Einstein also said-- and I
love this quote so much--
he said, regarding the
Copenhagen Interpretation,
that it was a soft pillow
that the true believer can
rest his head on, but it
provides very little comfort
to him.
Or he also said that--
again regarding the
Copenhagen Interpretation
and its denial of reality--
he said that this
epistemology fueled
orgy must come to an end.
And I went and looked
it up thinking,
OK maybe the translation
from the German
took a few liberties.
And it's right in there.
It's something like
epistemologies orgy.
So yeah, no, Einstein was
pretty clear about what
his problem was.
It's just not been
represented properly.
Yeah?
ALEX: Let's do an
online question first.
ADAM BECKER: OK and then
we can then alternate?
OK sounds good.
So what's the online question?
ALEX: What are your thoughts
on the Conway-Kochen Free Will
theorem, which basically
says that there
is a finite set of
experiments such
that there is no consistent set
of possible outcomes for all
the experiments?
ADAM BECKER: Yeah,
so this is a question
about my thoughts on the
Conway-Kochen Free Will
experiment.
It's a good question.
I'm going to say something
that will probably
piss off people in response.
The Conway-Kochen
Free Will theorem
is just an attempt to
repackage Bell's theorem
along with a different result
known as contextuality, which
is actually also due to Bell.
It was a Bell's demolition
of von Neumann's proof
that I talked about earlier.
I don't think that there
is anything in there that
isn't in those two proofs.
And I think that
mostly, what it means
is that there is non-locality
in nature or something else,
one of the other ways
out of Bell's theorem,
must be true like
multiple universes.
So yeah, maybe not the
most interesting response
to that, but I actually don't
find the result terribly
interesting either
AUDIENCE: So I find
it very surprising
that there are
prominent physicists who
don't think that
quantum mechanics is
unitary or violates other
neat mathematical properties.
It's non-local.
So I mean, you've had some
interesting discussions
with Peter White and
Sabine Hossenfelder
is also a prominent
blogger who doesn't
believe in the multiverse.
So what do the shut
up and calculate
people say happens in the
Schrodinger's cat scenario
for a sufficiently small cat?
ADAM BECKER: It's
a good question.
So first of all, let
me make it clear.
I am not saying, oh, the
multiverse is definitely true.
I am saying--
AUDIENCE: I am saying that.
ADAM BECKER: OK good.
Yeah, no, it's a viable option.
But well, some people
don't seem to understand
that that's what I'm saying.
I don't know.
I thought I made it pretty clear
in my book and in the talk.
So you're asking what the
Copenhagen Interpretation
people say happens to the
cat in Schrodinger's cat
for a sufficiently small cat.
That's an excellent question.
I am strongly tempted to
give a very glib answer
and say they don't say
what happens to the cat.
They don't say what
happens to anything
because their interpretation
is profoundly anti-realist.
If I wanted to be
more charitable,
I would say you have to pick
a version of the Copenhagen
Interpretation.
There is no single
Copenhagen Interpretation,
and arguably, it's not
interpretation at all.
So the phrase the
Copenhagen Interpretation
is a little bit like
the Holy Roman Empire.
There's no the, and
there's no interpretation
and the affiliation with
Copenhagen is questionable.
But if you pick a version
of Copenhagen, if you say,
OK, let's pick the version that
says quantum mechanics stops
applying at a
particular size scale,
then the answer of what happens
to the cat is reasonably clear.
If it's larger than
that size scale,
then the cat is
either dead or alive.
And if it's smaller, then the
cat is both dead and alive.
If you pick a version
of Copenhagen that says,
no, it's meaningless to ask
about what happens to the cat
before you look,
then the answer is,
we can't say what
happens to the cat
until you look because
it's meaningless.
Because that's what we said.
Because we don't
understand philosophy
of language or
metaphysics because we
didn't pay attention when the
logical positivists were taken
down in the mid 20th century.
But I definitely--
AUDIENCE: But then you can
get an interference pattern
of cats.
ADAM BECKER: I agree.
Yeah, no.
You can get an
interference pattern.
The interference
pattern is real.
I can't defend it
because they think
it's not just wrong, but
logically incoherent,
which makes it very, very
difficult to be sympathetic.
I have to pick a version of it.
And as far as I can tell,
the most reasonable version
of Copenhagen, which
some people, at least,
did believe at some
points is that there
is some sort of split between
the classical and the quantum.
It happens either at
some scale or when
it hits the brain because
the brain is somehow
exempt from the laws of physics.
Anyway.
Yeah.
ALEX: Let's take another
Dory question first.
Oh OK.
Free will is bogus,
and the world
is entirely deterministic.
Does this contradict
quantum physics?
What does it mean for
there to be no causation?
ADAM BECKER: OK.
So the question is about
whether quantum physics is
deterministic and
what it would mean
for there to be no causation.
Whether quantum physics
is deterministic
depends on your interpretation.
For example, the pilot
wave interpretation
is entirely deterministic.
The many-worlds interpretation
is entirely deterministic,
which is actually kind
of a problem for it
because you need to figure out
where the probabilities come
from.
|n the pilot wave
interpretation,
they come from ignorance.
In the many-worlds
interpretation,
you need to figure out
why we don't know things
because everything just obeys
this totally deterministic
Schrodinger equation.
But there are people who
work on that who think
they've found solutions to it.
It's an active area of research.
Nonetheless, that's
totally deterministic.
There are proposed modifications
to quantum mechanics
that would also solve the
measurement problem called
spontaneous collapse theories.
Those are fundamentally
non-deterministic.
So it depends on what you pick.
As for what it means for
things to not be deterministic,
it means that sometimes
the future of the world
is not fully specified by
the past state of the world.
AUDIENCE: An effort to figure
out the nature of the universe
and how the universe works,
until or unless it can come up
with some kind of device
that can measure or detect
that which energy
and mass actually is.
Because when you tear
apart both mass and energy,
eventually you're
left with nothing,
but obviously, mass energy
must be coming from something.
Do you think we'll ever come
up with some means made up
of mass or energy that
can detect that which
underlies mass and energy?
Do you think that's
ever possible?
ADAM BECKER: I think that mass
is just one form of energy.
I wouldn't say that
mass and energy
are two sides of the same coin.
I would say mass is
just one kind of energy,
and what's
fundamental is energy.
And that is the standard
view among most physicists,
and I think it's probably right.
Mass is a kind of energy the
same way kinetic energy is
a kind of energy, the same
way heat is a kind of-- well,
heat is a kind of
kinetic energy--
the same with that potential
energy is a kind of energy.
I think that what e equals
mc squared really says
is that mass is
a form of energy.
So yeah, I don't see a problem
there the way that you do.
AUDIENCE: Oh, OK.
Thank you.
ALEX: Let's go back to the Dory.
What is consciousness
according to quantum physics?
ADAM BECKER: I don't
see a relationship.
[LAUGHTER]
OK let me be less flip.
So I think that a
lot of people like
to say that consciousness
has some relationship
to quantum physics because
we don't fully understand
what consciousness is and
because there's controversy
over the solution of
the measurement problem.
So if we put together
the two things
that we don't
understand, maybe we'll
get just one thing
we don't understand.
And some serious physicists
have, at various points,
proposed that consciousness is
the solution to the measurement
problem, that it's consciousness
that collapses wave functions.
Eugene Wigner believed
this at one point
until he was set straight.
I don't think that
that's correct.
I think that if
that is correct, we
need to do a lot more work
to prove that it's correct
because there are definitely
viable alternatives to that
on the table.
I think that if consciousness
causes collapse,
we have questions like,
OK, what is consciousness.
By what virtues does
it cause collapse?
What property does
it have that allows
it to collapse wave functions?
What else can collapse
wave functions?
It's a whole host
of other problems.
And I don't think
quantum physics
itself says anything about
the nature of consciousness.
I think that that's--
what consciousness is, is a good
question for a different field.
AUDIENCE: So I remember reading
30 years ago these books,
following up to that, the
"Dancing Wu Li Masters"
and "The Tao of Consciousness".
And I think the whole
premise of those books
was what can cause a
collapse in these functions.
Is that basically the whole--
that was the whole misconception
of those books, that they based
their entire framework around?
ADAM BECKER: Yes, so
the question was--
AUDIENCE: And can
I ask a follow up,
which is what can cause a
collapse in this function.
ADAM BECKER: Sure, so first
I realized I never actually
repeated the original question.
I just answered.
Which was, what is consciousness
according to quantum physics.
That's the answer I just gave.
Your question was these books,
"The Dancing Wu Li Masters",
"The Tao of Physics", was
this about a misunderstanding
of what causes the collapse
of the wave function
and then what does cause the
collapse of the wave function.
I think that those books were--
full disclaimer, I
have not actually
read both of those books
from cover to cover.
I flipped through
them, but I think
that part of the
deal with those books
is that they are
interested in going
after these questions that were
seen as verboten for physicists
by the Copenhagen
Interpretation, which
the shut up part of
shut up and calculate
has a sort of
moralistic sense to it.
Like not only don't you
need to ask these questions,
you shouldn't ask
these questions.
Good physicists don't
ask these questions.
There's something wrong with
you if you ask these questions.
Which is bullshit.
But I think that
these books were
motivated in part by a desire
to ask those questions.
And then they said,
OK, and let's ask
other questions that are
verboten to physicists
like is there ESP.
What about telekinesis?
What about the relationship
between religion and quantum
physics, consciousness
and quantum physics?
And I think throwing in all that
stuff really confuses things,
but I think that they
were right to ask
the question of what's going
on in wave function collapse.
I also think that
they were motivated
by this sort of desire
to see similarities
between certain religions
and quantum physics.
And just to talk about
that for a second
before I get to your last
part of the question,
I think it's
generally a bad idea
to try to find parallels
between religion and science
because science has this
nasty habit of being refined
and corrected and proved wrong
or scientific theories get
overturned.
So if you try to latch
your religious philosophy
onto a particular
scientific truth,
there's a good chance that
your religious philosophy
is going to go down
the toilet when
that truth is found to be not
quite true or completely wrong.
So I'm not very sympathetic
to that project,
and I don't think
that people who
like religion should be either.
Anyway as for what actually
causes the collapse of the wave
function, I don't know.
I don't even know if
functions do collapse.
If they don't collapse,
we live in many worlds.
Or we have something like pilot
wave theory where it collapse,
it's something that's
relative to other stuff.
It's more complicated than that.
Or we have something like
a spontaneous collapse
theory where collapse
is a real objective
thing that happens at random.
Or one of the other options.
So I don't know what causes it.
But either wave function
collapse is happening
or something is causing it to
look like function collapse is
happening.
And figuring out
what's going on there
is a legitimate area of
scientific inquiry called
foundations of
quantum physics that
still has a bad reputation among
physicists even to this day,
though it's less bad
than it used to be.
ALEX: I've heard you mention
many times that there's
sort of this big split between
physicists and philosophers
of physics because
physicists don't know
any philosophy while
philosophers of physics
know a lot of physics.
I'm also thinking of--
I'm probably going to
misquote it, a quote by--
I think it might be
some modern philosopher.
It might be Dan Dennett--
I don't know-- who
said something like,
there's no science
without philosophy.
There's only science with
unexamined philosophy
or something like that, which--
ADAM BECKER: Yeah that sounds
like something Dennett would
say.
ALEX: Yeah, and
so I thought maybe
you might want to
comment on why is
it that physicists don't
know any philosophy any more
at least?
ADAM BECKER: This is
a very good question.
So the question is about
why physicists mostly
don't seem to know
philosophy, but philosophers
of physics, the serious ones,
tend to be very well schooled
in physics.
Many of them have
undergraduate or even
PhDs in physics as
well as philosophy.
Yeah, there's definitely
an asymmetry there
where the philosophers
know much more
physics than the
physicists know philosophy.
As a physicist, I'm
interested in asymmetries.
So yeah.
I think that basically,
this is due to a variety
of historical and
cultural factors.
I think that that quote, whether
it's Dan Dennett or whoever who
said that, it's definitely
true that physicists
engage in philosophy all the
time while doing physics.
It's just part of it.
And then the question is, OK
why don't they admit that.
Why don't they look at this?
Well, philosophy has a
bit of a bad reputation
among physicists.
So why does it have
a bad reputation?
That's a hard
question to answer.
I think part of it has to do
with those same factors at work
after World War II where
academia just got flooded
with more people and this led
to a sort of Balkanization
of academia and the walls
went up between departments.
It used to be that
physicists generally had
some schooling in philosophy.
Now, that's not necessary.
I'm not saying that we should
go back to the good old days.
There are plenty of problems.
But I do think
that a liberal arts
education is quite valuable
for doing almost anything.
But I think that due to
that set of boundaries
between academic
disciplines, that
has made it easy for physicists
to be ignorant of philosophy.
And then it's easy
for misconceptions
about philosophy, like
it doesn't make progress,
they just ask the
same questions over
and over again, they're
not like us physicists,
that kind of thing to show up.
Philosophers also
have a habit of asking
very annoying questions.
This is a long and
proud tradition
going back to Socrates.
Now most of us don't have to
drink hemlock as a result.
But one way of dismissing
annoying questions
is to say that the people who
ask the annoying questions
are stupid and don't
need to be listened to.
Or you make them drink hemlock.
So that's another thing.
I think that there are
some philosophers who are,
let's say, skeptical
of scientific progress.
This has to do with a
split within philosophy
between analytic and
continental philosophy,
which is a whole other thing.
And those names are
incidentally not relevant at all
to what those fields study.
They're just
historical artifacts.
But continental philosophy
tends to be a little bit more
skeptical of authority in
any form and in many ways,
rightly so.
And it tends to ask questions
about scientific authority,
which if you interpret
them naively or if you're
a bad continental philosopher,
can lead to people saying
things like, oh science is
just as good as any other way
of trying to solve problems.
And that's some bullshit.
And scientists would be
rightly dismissive of that,
and then they might lump
all other philosophers
in with that.
But that's just a
guess on my part.
So I think that,
basically, philosophy
has a very bad reputation
for a variety of reasons.
It used to not.
Bohr did read too
much Kant, but it's
better than reading nothing.
Einstein read a lot
of Mach and Leibniz
and Spinoza and other
great philosophers, Hume
in particular.
Yeah, I think that
it's a real shame
that that asymmetry is there.
I think that
philosophers of physics
have a lot to teach physicists
and have a lot of value
to offer.
And I think it's really awful
when prominent scientists say
stupid things about
philosophy, which happens
more often than it should.
ALEX: So the next
question is, what
about the success of quantum
electrodynamics in predicting?
I mean, it seems
like your answer
is the past hour-long
talk, roughly.
ADAM BECKER: Yeah.
So the success of quantum
electrodynamics, yeah,
absolutely.
Quantum electrodynamics
and quantum field theories
in general are
extremely successful.
I'm not debating the
success of quantum physics.
It absolutely works.
It's just an incomplete
picture of what's
going on in the world.
And throwing in quantum
field theory, as opposed
to just vanilla
quantum mechanics,
doesn't fix the problem.
If anything, it makes it worse.
Some people will say, oh,
quantum field theory definitely
gets you around Bell's
theorem because quantum field
theory is designed
to be compatible
with special relativity.
There are these things called
the commutation relations
that ensure this relationship.
No, that doesn't solve
the problem at all
because you still have the
problem of wave function
collapse in quantum
field theory.
And that is subject
to Bell's theorem,
and that does not get solved
by the commutation relations.
And this is a massive
misunderstanding that still
persists among physicists.
And that's just a
mathematical mistake.
That's just an error.
Quantum field theory
doesn't solve this problem.
also has other problems.
It works incredibly
well, but it also
has its own unique issues
that mathematicians
worry about like
re-normalization
or something called
Hogg's theorem, which--
don't get me started.
ALEX: I won't.
ADAM BECKER: Yeah, anyway.
So yeah.
Quantum field theory is great.
I love it.
It is a wonderful theory.
Doesn't solve these problems.
ALEX: OK, we have time
for one more question.
So since you haven't had time.
AUDIENCE: Just a follow-up
to your previous answer.
Without speculating
about why physicists
have a bad image of philosophy,
can you, from your research,
pinpoint when this attitude--
when did physicists
start to have a bad
image of philosophy?
Since you're a physicist
and a philosopher,
can you give us your
attitude towards philosophy?
Noting that your answer
doesn't need to be monolithic,
is there some part of philosophy
that you think is worthwhile?
ADAM BECKER: I don't
know exactly when
the split happened.
I don't think it's something
that happened all at once.
I think that World
War II has a lot
to do with it, which is in
a way kind of boring answer.
Like one of the central
events of the 20th century
had a lot of effect.
That's a somewhat boring answer.
But yeah, I mean,
World War II really
changed the way that
academia worked.
It really moved the center of
physics from Germany to the US.
The US already had a tradition
of much more pragmatic
approaches to the
sciences, which--
that's going to make
philosophy look less useful.
There was also this
school of thought
called logical
positivism, which was
very influential in the first
half of the 20th century.
And it was also a
school of thought
which was dismissive of
certain kinds of philosophy.
And then, around the time that
physics and philosophy kind of
decoupled around the end of
World War II, that was also
the beginning of the real
decline of logical positivism,
even among philosophers who
were sympathetic to the aims
of the positivists.
And so by the time positivism
was fully discredited,
physicists couldn't
really get the memo
and still used a lot of
positivist-ish arguments,
really knock-off positivist
arguments like, oh,
it's meaningless to talk about
things that you can't see.
They would use those arguments
to dismiss most of philosophy
when, in fact, philosophy
is decades old counter
arguments explaining
why that doesn't work.
And when you present
those to physicists,
they will sort of stare at
you slack jawed like did you
come up with that yourself.
That seems very profound.
No, that argument is older
than both of us combined.
So yeah.
As for my take on philosophy,
I think that in general, it
is usually a bad idea to
dismiss almost any area
of serious academic inquiry.
There are exceptions, such
as evolutionary psychology.
I like psychology.
Evolutionary psychology?
But I think that
most of philosophy
has something worthwhile.
I think philosophy of physics,
in the analytic tradition,
has done a lot of
really great work
in particular because it's
gone after these questions
that physicists have
largely ignored.
But I also think that
philosophy of science
really helps to clear up a
lot of misunderstandings that
are prevalent among scientists
of all stripes about how
science works.
There are some naive ideas
there that philosophers
have help to kick to the curb.
I think that if you think
that you have a simple answer
to a deep question, talking to
a philosopher for a few minutes
will usually tell you
that you're wrong.
And I think that it's good
to experience being wrong.
I think that's an important
part of the human experience,
and I think that it's
good to think deeply
about strange questions.
And I think that the questions
philosophers tend to ask--
and this might be another
source of the problem--
philosophers will ask
questions that sound
like they have obvious
answers to scientists.
Like OK, what is a physical law?
OK, that doesn't
seem interesting.
That seems obvious.
And then they go on about it for
five minutes, like oh, OK yeah.
I see what they're asking, but
I think there's an easy answer.
And then they go on about
it for 10 more minutes,
and you realize you don't
even know where the hell
you are anymore.
And I mean, I think that
that's a really good experience
to have.
I think it's good to
understand weight.
These things that
we take for granted
might be way more
complicated than we think.
And there is also a
long and proud tradition
in science of doing science
and damn the torpedoes,
forget the philosophical or
mathematical foundations.
I'm not even saying that
shut up and calculate
was always the wrong approach.
It's certainly not the case
that every single physicist
should be thinking about quantum
foundations all the time.
It's just that
moralistic thing of no,
you should shut
up and calculate,
a good physicist shuts
up and calculates.
That's some bullshit.
These questions are
legitimate parts of science,
and the boundary between
science and philosophy
is and always has been
permeable, just as it
is between any two disciplines.
ALEX: And yeah, it's
been a pleasure.
And thank you all
of you for coming.
ADAM BECKER: Yeah, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]